we've been following what I have
generally characterized as a definitive
and decided war on Free Press by the
Trump administration and this has
multiple components and none of these
should come as a surprise to you because
I've been talking about these over time
the idea of the media as the enemy of
the American people that having trouble
today I can't I can't imagine why
journalism licenses being required to
practice media libel lawsuits made
easier we had of course countless tweets
from Donald Trump about this including
the following tweet the fake news media
failing New York Times NBC News ABC CBS
CNN is not my enemy it is the enemy of
the American people and last week during
a Jim Acosta and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
it's being described as an exchange I
call it more of a kerfuffle I think
maybe high rated a tirade of sorts the
White House refused to deny that the
press was the enemy of the American
people and in fact I would argue Sarah
Huckabee Sanders sort of confirmed it by
saying Trump has already told us what
his position is on that and I speak on
the behalf of the President and we now
have a new poll to sort of add to our
fleshing out of whether this is a
strategy that's working 43 percent not
4.3 percent not 14.3%
not 24.3% 43 percent nearly half of
Republicans believe that Donald Trump
should be able to unilaterally just say
this media outlet it's over whatever the
year fired equivalent is that you would
say to a media outlet when they're going
away 48% of Republicans in the same poll
agree that the media is the enemy of the
American people and this is where you
have to understand the I don't want to
call it brilliance but the power of
these campaigns by Trump where even
without saying straight up all media is
the enemy of the American people or
media in principle are the enemies of
the American people half of Republicans
are believing it and dump Trump didn't
even have to say it in as explicit terms
as he could have now in comparison 12%
of Democrats and 21% of independents
agree
about president Trump closing down media
outlets those numbers are still higher
than I would like to see right like the
number should be if anyone who
understands America is asked should the
president be able to say you are off the
air the answer should always be no we
have systems in place we have limits as
to what can legally be reported if your
FCC bound because of your broadcast
platforms there are rules governing the
answer should never be yes the president
should get to say you're off the air
whether it's 12% for Dems 21 for
independents or 43 for Republicans it's
all horrible yeah I'd like to see it at
0% of course we'll never get that maybe
just a few percentage points I would
take because this is the American public
after all very well you it's hard to get
zero percent of Americans agreeing on
anything right let me go to a different
way it's hard to get a hundred percent
of Americans agreeing on anything
overall 57 percent of respondents
believe that media is necessary to keep
the Trump administration honest I would
agree with that
13% of Americans agreed that President
Trump should close down mainstream news
outlets like CNN The Washington Post in
the New York Times what I go to is
number one there's a partisan element
right like if a Democrat were president
right now you would probably see
Democrats to a slightly higher degree
saying Obama should get to close down
whatever and Republicans lower but it's
not just hypocrisy there is no question
that the so-called constitutional
conservatives who claim to be all about
the Bill of Rights and separation of
powers and checks and balances and all
this stuff they seemed completely
unconcerned with the fact that there is
nothing in the First Amendment which
would allow for a president to just say
this media outlet doesn't get to
continue or that media outlet doesn't
get to continue and part of what has
been going on that predates the Trump
administration that fuels this is a
distrust of media in general right in
addition to the likely partisan divide
that there is in general you have a high
distrust of media and I often have asked
about this right people will say to me
David
if
you're so often critical of media
outlets how are you now worried about
the fact that Trump is criticizing media
what you have to understand is there's a
difference between identifying a
particular media outlet that's doing bad
reporting and criticizing them that's
one thing versus me saying the president
should get to pick which media outlets
exist these are completely unrelated
problems that we're dealing with and
unfortunately a lot of people are going
in the wrong direction on this
seventy-two percent of respondents
believe it should be easier to sue
reporters willingly publishing false
information remember the key word is
easier there's already laws that prevent
reporters or punish reporters from
punishing Ephrem publishing willingly
false information and it's working and
it's being reflected by Trump's own
followers here's one example where CNN's
reporter Jim Acosta was just yelled at
and badgered during a Trump rally in
Florida recently
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so there are a number of disturbing
angles to this generally number one the
authoritarian tendencies shutting down
media lack of press freedom right we see
this in places like Venezuela we've seen
it in China North Korea Turkey doesn't
like the internet we heard from
president air21 that he's increasingly
against the internet every day when you
see leaders one thing to have this level
of control that is an authoritarian
tendency and worse when you've got half
of one party saying you want them to
have that control that is really really
scary beyond that I already mentioned
there's the constitutional angle here
what exceptions are there to freedom of
the press that would allow a president
to close down a media outlet but in the
end it's just more hypocrisy than it is
anything else the principles don't
matter
there is a contingent out there and it
is where the Alex Jones story brought a
lot of them out right when it's Alex
Jones being taken off of youtube youtube
is unjustifiably censoring Alex Jones
which isn't the government by the way
but then all of a sudden Republicans are
asked would you want the president
meaning the government to just be able
to select media outlets to shut down and
half of them say yes it doesn't Square
there is no way where both of those
views can be held simultaneously without
huge cognitive dissonance I think we all
see what Trump is doing here I don't
think he would actively pursue shutting
down media outlets and he wouldn't say
anything for that effect but he calls
the media fake news and he builds this
distrust among his supporters so that
they then fill in the blanks and reason
that it's important for us to shut down
these outlets Trump's goal is to not
have to shut down the media outlets to
make them completely uneffective if you
turn public opinion against them enough
if you frame them as the enemies of the
American people and simultaneously
spread so much diss and misinformation
that people don't know what to believe
you won't need to shut down any of the
media outlets because they won't be
functioning as intended to begin with